despojados de cualquier rastro de
humanidad así llegan los 2000 primeros
presos a la prisión más grande de
América Latina en El Salvador hoy en la
madrugada en un solo operativo
trasladamos a los primeros 2000
pandilleros al centro de confinamiento
del terrorismo esta Será su nueva casa
donde vivirán por décadas mezclados sin
poder hacerle más daño a la población el
megaproyecto del presidente salvadoreño
nayib bukele tiene capacidad para 40.000
personas su construcción fue criticada
por la oposición señalando falta de
transparencia tras la aprobación de la
oficialista asamblea legislativa pero
las duras políticas de bukele contra las
pandillas gozan de una gran popularidad
entre los salvadoreños que dicen
sentirse más seguros en las calles desde
que declaró el estado de emergencia hace
casi un año las autoridades Han detenido
a más de 64.000 personas acusadas de
pandilleros y las tasas de homicidio se
han reducido drásticamente el denominado
centro de confinamiento del terrorismo
situado en la ciudad de tecoluca
darte en la particular batalla del
mandatario contra la violencia
célula célula estamos eliminando este
cáncer de la sociedad sepan que no
volverán a salir caminando del secot
pagarán por lo que son cobardes
terroristas el país centroamericano
tiene la tasa de encarcelamiento más
alta del mundo si bien la percepción de
seguridad ha cambiado en El Salvador el
costo es enorme para la democracia y los
Derechos Humanos como denuncian varias
organizaciones humanitarias que aseguran
que el gobierno incurre en violaciones
torturas y asesinatos dentro de estas
prisiones